michael was a brilliantly talented actor
and a generous human being who has left
us far too soon
michael k williams was honored at the
2021 emmy awards on sunday night less
than two weeks after his tragic death
you know
in honor of michael we plan to dance
because that's what he did so well
and you know there's something about the
way michael lived his life and the
amount of joy that he brought to all our
lives
that
we want to celebrate tonight williams
who died on september 6 at the age of 54
was nominated for outstanding supporting
actor in a drama series for his
performance on hbo's lovecraft country
and before presenting the award kerry
washington took a moment to pay tribute
to the late actor michael was
crazy to say was michael was
a brilliantly talented actor and a
generous human being who has left us far
too soon
michael
i know you're here because you wouldn't
miss this your excellence your artistry
will endure we love you though williams
had been considered the front-runner to
posthumously win the emmy which would
have been the first of his career the
award ultimately went to tobias menzies
for his role as prince philip on the
crown i know this night is bittersweet
for you all because you're missing um
part of the the soul of this of this
show
michael callie kenneth williams yeah
i was um i heard that you guys wanted to
honor him that you maybe had some pins
made you wanted to do something let's
see oh that's beautiful
e.t caught up with williams loved craft
country co-stars journey smallit and
misha green on the red carpet before the
big show and they opened up about the
special way they were honoring their
friend what was the thought behind just
wanting to do this just wanting to have
a little piece of something here to
remind everyone to remind us that there
was supposed to be someone here with us
absolutely yeah he is here with us you
know he's here in spirit i can feel him
in little moments and
and his work is just so profound in
everything that he's done but
particularly what he brought to montrose
was just so special and brave and so
it's just our way of honoring williams
was also honored during the show's in
memoriam segment the only way for me to
say thank you
is by making sure that the foundation
that i am standing on is strong enough
to support
the next person that will stand on these
two shoulders
leon bridges sang his song river and
before the show he told et about what
made the moment so special man it's it's
it's been heartbreaking you know
recently you know ran into michael
michael k williams you know at a at um
this spot called doheny room and
you know we chopped it up for a minute
and
it was just rad that
you know some somebody that i look up to
is you know was a fan of my art you know
and so
it's an honor to be here tonight and
you know and play play play a tune but
leon wasn't the only star to open up
about the late actor he's just such a
great spirit he just lit up a room
wherever he went
he lifted people up so it's just a loss
for the world tonight also a little
bittersweet because of michael k
williams and we miss him your thoughts
about michael
i can't even go there kevin because it's
still a little bit too
soon for me
you know but we do miss him and we love
him and he was my friend
and uh
you know we're gonna be celebrating him
tonight as well
[Music]